if you've ever looked at pictures from
your past or you look at a picture of
you with old friends doing something we
tend to feel these feelings of nostalgia
what is Nostalgia so to me Nostalgia is
gratitude in the present for past
circumstances and what's interesting
about Nostalgia is that for whatever
reason we're able to kind of look past
all of the minutia of how we were
feeling our moods and we're able to kind
of like see big picture the things that
we are grateful for I tried to do this I
woke up thinking to myself if I were 85
years old and I got to go through a time
machine and be back in my body as I am
now to experience my life as though I'm
experiencing the day that I'm about to
live from my 85 year old self seeing it
again if I wake up and I go I remember
when we used to live here this is so
nice for whatever reason gratitude
journals the meditations things like
that like I don't feel that but thinking
about my 85 year old self being able to
re-experience life through my 32 year
old body as though I'm going through it
the second time the first time it's
really shifted how I see things